Ngày mới chỉ nguyên nân tổng thống Mỹ đuôn nền Chủ biết,
Washington có thể biến hành thêm có cụ tấn công nhằm vào Iran
nếu hai bên không đàn được thỏa thuận với Chủ chính hạc nhân
và có bánh đề án linh khu vực.
Theo hẳng tình và tư tổng thống trong pháp biểu tả nhà trắng rằng
Mỹ tương ở rất cân quy định mở lại chiến dịch quân sự
nhưng đã tạm hóa í sâu để sớm mới từ Tây Van.
Nha lãnh hỏng Mỹ khỏng định, Evan không thể sử vụ kiện hạc nhân
và cho rằng Tây Van là tiểu kiến mua thả thuận
nha không trắng theo thằng thằng,
từ Dr. Van đã giúp gần đây som thường giận biểu tình sang lịch
là chừng thống nhất quả via Iran và hóa khó khăn
via via Tehran.
Și in thông nha nước Iran cho biết nếu nay yêu cầu Mỹ giữa bỏ tálệch
trên pháp.
Hãy gọi phóng tài đảnh sản bị phông tóa và chấm rất các biện pháp phong tóa
hành lồn thời tuyên bố, tây Van sẵn gi whatsoever đất chả cuối liệt.
Nếu Mỹ vẫn gi grow tính hành thêm các hình động của dự.
Con thành thẵn Mỹ Ivan tý tục tố sở in chú ý của cậm đều bú tệ,
Chưa bất cảnh có cuộc súng độ tại Trung đó và vấn đề án đình nâng lượng toàn cầu vẫn dẹp biển phức tạm.